hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today we're gonna talk about the new
content of the week as that's all that's
really happening this week but it has to
do with the video we talked about last
time which was those musical emote
executions we saw so it's always like to
be if you do enjoy subscribers we knew I
covered the informational slide a
foreigner that being the balance changes
to hear updates the passwords and the
leaks you've got to be kept today with
everything happening in the world a
foreigner never miss out an update that
we stay subscribe the channel and with
that let's get started with today's
video all Jesus if my voice sounds a
little bit different than normal I had
just woken up so apologies for that but
for today's video like we talked about
the executions in last video that we
were kind of teased about in the trailer
those musical ones we discussed we only
got to saw two well we got to see all
four of them in their glory because
they're actually releasing today right
now if you go into the game you can see
all of them and you can buy them of
course as long as you have to steal I'll
be playing them on screen right now and
I personally like this theme of the
enemy dying and trying to save their
life and get spared through song but
doing a terrible job at it and getting
absolutely destroyed for it so shout out
to you before that creative idea and for
my honest opinion I love it I told you
guys in the last video the flute was
definitely gonna be one of the best ones
just for the potential that they could
do with the flute and they didn't
disappoint you literally shoved the flew
down back into their windpipe and I
think that's the best part
another thing that also released I think
it like the end of last week that I
didn't get a chance to make a video on
since there wasn't really too much
information I wanted to save it for a
full Thursday video was actually a road
map for June I will put it up after the
executions are finished but there really
wasn't much to be honest since it's the
June roadmap and the entire event ends
July 2nd pretty much all of you is gonna
be caked with Fullwood stuff happening
with the event the only notable thing is
I believe that something in regards to
content of the weekend next week and
then some more loot fest stuff towards
the end of the week after that but
that's just about it obviously it's the
event that's the biggest part so there's
obviously gonna be really good content
for the event but there isn't going to
be any other diverse things like maybe
there's
coming or maybe there's like secret
stuff being released nothing really in
regards to that of course and still in
the middle of an event July we'll
definitely have some more interesting
stuff as well but we'll have to see when
we get there yeah that's gonna be the
end of the video today guys like I said
it was just gonna be a really quick
video just showing off the executions
nothing too crazy at the very end when I
stop talking I will show the execution
video again it this is gonna have sound
and not me talking as you can hear the
music instruments actually make noise
and if you really wanted to hear that
part of course I will leave that in the
video what if you just wanted to see the
visual version didn't really care about
the small noises they made then you got
that part too but yeah it'll be at the
end of this video so as long as like TV
do enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the informational side of foreigner that
means the balance changes to hear
updates the Patchett's and leaks if
anybody kept it today with everything
happening in the world foreigner I never
saw an update that we stay subscribe to
the channel and that guys enjoy the
executions at the end of this video and
peace out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]